hi my name is Philip and I have a
question about like when you're writing
the different conflicts in Westeros do
you ever like personally bacon asides or
feel with one side fights for more just
cause subjectively than the other yeah
certainly
I mean I've often said that I don't I
believe in great characters I don't
believe in black and white characters I
don't want to write the band of heroes
on one side and the orcs on the other
side but that's not to say that that old
characters are equally quare it gray you
know some are very dark gray and some
are some are mostly white but they still
have occasional flaws in them you know
I'm I'm I've always been fascinated by
human beings and all their complexity
and even newbies who do polling things
you know the question is why why are
they do appalling things and it's
interesting to get inside the head and
and see why you know some of my
viewpoint characters are have done some
incredibly reprehensible things Theon
for example or Victorian Greyjoy why why
have they done those things well they
just like born a monster weren't they
born a you know a cute little kid
running around and saying why is the sky
blue mommy and you know wanting to be
loved and all that we all start out that
way right but things happen to us along
the way that lead us to junctures in our
life where we make decisions and those
decisions and the consequences of them
call her everything that comes after and
colors the perception of of the people I
mean I was I got a tour through here
beforehand and we were being shown some
of the armor any artifacts of the
various Swedish Kings gustavus adolphus
and Charles the 12th and some of these
others and you know you look at that
mancine what's the verdict the history
on these men are these heroes or they're
villains are they great people or people
that we should despise I mean it's
different they're fascinating characters
because
they're they're very complexity I
actually was speaking about I mean when
you mention great people or not I mean I
think there was once back in late sort
of a splits in in how you viewed history
romanticism kind of came the great man
theory of history that history was made
by great men and more modern history is
much more of a stronger fee of societies
of a sociology to me when I read this
always the fire it feels very much of a
romantic taking that sense it's the
characters are great men doing great
things and yet when you come to a feast
for crows to me that's a novel where you
say let's step back and let's see what
these great men have wrought is that
something that you did deliberately yeah